good afternoon welcome to uh ee 380 the
Stanford computer systems colloquium
um our speaker today is Peter rakita
uh he's uh from Budapest Hungary and has
been uh studying uh Quantum Computing
for a number of years uh he speaks today
on highly optimized Quantum circuits
synthesized via dataflow engines
um in any case um Peter uh thank you
very much for doing to your talk I think
this is going to be a a very interesting
thing and I'm looking forward to uh
hearing what you have to say so I'm
leave to you the uh the problem of uh
introducing yourself and uh your work
thank you very much again okay welcome
everyone uh first of all I am very
grateful for the invitation
my story is that uh I started to to work
with Quantum Computing two years ago
when I got the opportunity to join the
National Hungarian program of quantum
information
basically we formed here a new research
group and the aim of this group was to
bring together people coming from quite
different
field of expertise
and the collaboration with the grok and
Max Air technical Technologies are are
in line with these concept because we
could further extend our
repertoire of of a very useful tools to
solve computational problems
uh one of our project
benefiting from this collaboration is
the
is is about Quantum gate decomposition
meaning that uh okay the central
question here is to how to compile
Quantum programs in terms of Elementary
operations that can be executed on real
Quantum Hardware
okay uh
ideally a Time evolution of quantum
mechanical systems can be described by a
unitary matrices because these are the
operation that preserves the norm of the
quantum mechanical State and these
unitary operations can describe either
the whole Quantum program or the
elementary gate operations or whatever
okay
I am assuming you you know that
all of such uh Quantum logical gates are
are transforming the state of the qubit
register and each qubit is is an
elementary unit of quantum information
here you can have instead of two
distinct
values of 0 and 1 you can have a
superposition of of uh of State 0 and 1.
and according to Quantum Mechanics we
can visualize the state of the quantum
qubit as a as a three-dimensional unit
Vector pointing at some position on on a
sphere this is called block sphere and
each physical transformation on a qubit
can be
mapped at the as a rotation of these
three-dimensional Vector over the block
sphere these single qubit rotation are
are labeled by these purple boxes over
the timeline of the timelines of the
qubits another
class of
of quantum logical gates are the ones
which are applied on more qubits at once
for example here you can see a so-called
C note gate
which depending on a state of one qubit
makes or makes no transformation on
another qubit
uh so this transformation also has an
analogy in In classical Information
Technology but in quantum mechanics it
has a much deeper meaning
in particular we can introduce
entanglement between qubits using such
multi-cubit Gates
the entanglement is a very particular
thing in quantum mechanics basically
it's an invisible wire between two
qubits or or or or particles meaning
that the state of one particle has a
direct effect on the state of the other
particle without having any wires or any
other physical interaction between them
you may probably heard about
the Nobel Prize this year which was
given to three feedstates demonstrating
this kind of quantum mechanical nature
between between
photons okay so this is a very
fundamental resource to do Quantum
computing
together with the superposition state of
the qubits
it is also an important to to notice at
this point that this single qubit
logical Gates together with these two
qubit C note Gates form the so-called
Universal gauge set meaning that any
Quantum program can be expressed as a
sequence of these logical operations
okay mathematically the problem is to
expand a quantum mechanical program
labeled by you in terms of a product of
many other unitaries like here in this
expression but you know this is
inevitable to to run any program on
Quantum Hardware so we need some kind of
a solution for for this even if if it is
a hard problem and they have there have
been developed many strategies to to
solve this problem some of them are full
of a deterministic algorithm
like the one applied in in Universal
compiler incorporated into the key skit
or ticket coming from Cambridge
this solution follows some some
complicated
theorems and rules coming from linear
algebra the problem with this solution
is that they produce Quantum circuits
with too much gate operations you know
these days we have noisy Quantum
processors and by accumulating the error
over many Quantum gate operations at the
end you won't get any reasonable outcome
from the processor so you need somehow
to compress this circuit
uh to contain fewer operations and
that's the way how you can get some
reasonable outputs from from Quantum
processors
another class of quantum compilers are
about to to solve this problem they are
they basically are reformulating these
synthesis process of of the compilation
into a optimization problem
so they are trying to approximate a
Quantum program labeled by you in the
previous Slide by a Quantum circuit and
by optimizing the parameters of the
circuit they are trying to get closer
and closer to the original Quantum
program U to this end we need to come up
with a
with a way how to how to uh uh
quantitatively compare the uh the
quantum program we are about to compile
with this circuit we need to come up
with some Metric to to quantify the
distance between these two two
quantities and this can be done
following a very simple physical idea
let's say this U is the original Quantum
program we are about to run on the
processor and the V is the unitary that
we extract from The Trial
Quantum circuit that we are using to
approximate the quantum program U if
these two unitaries are equivalent to
each other then by applying them as a
Time Evolution to a physical state
we are expecting to get equivalent
critical State meaning that the inner
product of this state would be uh would
be Unity
you know and if we take an average of
these inner product over the whole
universe space
of the quantum mechanical state
we should get uh
Unity as well if these two unitaries are
equal to each other if they are if they
differ from each other
then this integral would differ from
Unity it would be less than Unity so
this integral is called Fidelity it's a
quantitative they have to have to
characterize the
the uh the difference between these two
uh unitaries you and and V and after
some math
uh it can be shown that this integral
can be easily calculated with the
uh with the cost function called Hilbert
Schmidt test which is uh basically a
trace of the product of these two
matrices
and the the Fidelity can be calculated
using this simple
formula in exactly the composition the
Fidelity is is one as I just explained
and in this case this function C reaches
its minimum
uh minimum zero
okay
so this Hilbert Schmidt test can be the
cost function in the optimization
problem if if we find its minimum then
we can find the
the approximation of the quantum program
U
there is an even
simpler form for the cost function based
on the frogenous norm which is the sum
of the square of the Matrix elements
so if we calculate this Norm for the
difference between the matrices V and U
we again get the trace of these two
matrices but this time only on a
it is linearly involved in the
expression and we need only just the
real part from it
and if we introduce a new formula for
the Fidelity based on this frobenius
Norm it can be shown that this Fidelity
is always less than the Fidelity from
the previous slide so if we find the
solution for the optimization problem
using this this course function it will
be also a solution for the
optimization problem with the cost
function from the previous slide which
was physically I think much better
Justified
okay but having the cost function it's
not enough to to solve the the problem
we need to introduce a model to
parameterize the the quantum uh circuit
because you know the three parameters
which are encoded in those rotation
angles of the single qubit operations
for example are encoded within this
Matrix V
there are many strategies how to come up
with such models I will
describe some of them for you just to
get a feeling about the variety of of
this field
uh for example here is the strategy
implemented in in queue search developed
by Berkeley National Laboratory
here the parameterization of the circuit
is treated as it is as a combinatorial
problem
basically the quantum circuit can be
break down
down to two qubit Building Blocks made
of
uh two qubit gates like C node gate and
two single qubit uh rotations and you
know you can
you can start to build up your Quantum
circuit made of such two qubit building
blocks and here in this queue search
implementation they try to solve the
optimization problem in at each node of
this search tree this way they can get
very nice Quantum circuit very closely
approximating the original Quantum
program but the execution time of this
algorithm scales very badly
of course
another way
also developed by Berkeley National
Laboratory tries to break down the
initial and qubit unitary
into the product of smaller of of into a
product of unitaries acting on some
subsets of the of the qubit register for
example acting only on the half of the
of the qubit this can be done by
[Music]
um
by this general parameterization of
unitary metricities you know by limiting
the parameter Alpha
some components of of this parameter
Vector 2 to 0 you can exclude a basis
from this parametrization and this way
you can limit the action of the
resulting unitary uh
done to subsets of the initial qubit
register
and this step can be iteratively
repeated until
having a single or two qubit
unitaries which can be analytically
decomposed okay this algorithm scales
much better okay the execution time of
these algorithms gets much better than
the previous one but due to the general
nature of this parameterization the
produce circuit is usually significantly
uh deeper containing more operations
now I would like to
describe you the strategy developed in
our group and in implemented in the
squander
package which is an acronym for
Signature Quantum gay decomposer I want
to go into detail about
About This Acronym because it would take
a long time I will just briefly describe
you our algorithm we are also building
up our Quantum circuit from two qubit
building blocks but instead having uh
C naught operations
we are having a parametric two qubit
gates in this two qubit building block
this parametric
okay the nice thing about this
parametric two qubit gate is that
they can be
represented by a
let's say a single parameter and
depending on the value of this parameter
this gate can be
turned into a simple identity gate in
which case it can be simply excluded
from the circuit so the strategy is to
put many of such two qubit building
blocks into the quantum circuit
try to solve the optimization problem
and then exclude from the circuit uh
as much of these two qubit building
block as much it is possible using for
example this identity of turning some of
them into uh
and identificate
what uh gates are u3 here u3 are single
qubit rotation
okay these are rotating the the unit
Vector along the the block sphere okay
you usually they have three free
parameters because you can parameterize
the rotation in three-dimensional space
with the
with three three parameters so they're
also they're also parametric
yes of course all right okay this single
qubit parameters are parametric yes
okay uh we use this strategy in our uh
decomposing uh or Quantum compiler tool
and of course we made a comparison
between these these strategies
uh for example we try to decompose
Quantum programs available in an online
database which was published as a part
of his key developer challenge several
years ago or we can also do the
comparison on on on Sunday and on
algorithms like groover search or
Quantum Fourier transformation and and
so on
our Benchmark results are summarized in
this table
basically we are showing the gate count
of the C naught operations you know in
in
experimental setups the realization of
these two qubit gates are much much
harder than the realization of single
qubit Gates so that's the reason
why it is a common practice
to
to characterize the complexity of the
quantum circuit circuit with the count
of these two qubit gates
and if you compare our results you would
see that squander this is our tool
uh generated Quantum circuit having a
systematically
less of these three node Gates than the
other two optimization based algorithms
only one example is here
for whichever tool produced
higher C note gate count but this was a
this is a very special
three qubit
program having very few gates in it
uh
comparing with with other
or continue The Benchmark using other
examples our squander tool steel shows
a better performance than the the other
ones it is also interesting to compare
the results of this optimization based
algorithms the deterministic ones for
example implemented in the kiskit
package you see that there is a real
difference between the C naught gatecant
kiss kit produced a Quantum circuit
having
uh C naught Gates almost 10 times more
in the quantum circuits so it's a huge
difference the problem is
that uh kiss kit can do this
decomposition within several seconds
but the time scale of
of optimization based Quantum compilers
it's it's much higher so this is the uh
uh this is the problem with the
optimization based compilers we also can
compare the C node gate count with the
initial C note gate count you know all
of these example Quantum programs are
given in form of quantum circuit in that
online data by online database I just
mentioned two slides ago and you can see
that in many KDs
squander could give a better
decomposition than than it was
originally given in the database which
is also a very nice thing and the the
optimism the the Fidelity of all of
these circuits produced by squander or Q
first or Q search are very very close to
Unity so maybe they are even in exactly
compositions we we don't know for sure
but we just can tell that they are very
close to the exact the composition
and due to the uh high or long execution
time there is an other issue related to
the optimization based compilers namely
that all of these examples are at most
five qubit
programs so there are no more Cubit than
five in these Quantum programs
and the reason is
that the evaluation of the cost function
during the optimization procedure is
very expensive okay
basically you you you need to evaluate
the unitary V
associated with the trial Quantum
circuit or more efficient is to apply
the quantum circuit directly on on
unitary U dagger and this where you you
will get the product of these two
unitaries the problem is that the
unitary U is in general a dense Matrix
and you need to transform all of its
elements making
uh the number of operations to be four
on the power of n where n is the number
of qubits you know the size of this
matrices is 2 on the N times two on the
end and having uh
M uh Quantum gates in the circuit you
will need to repeat this procedure and
and time so it increases linearly the
complexity of of the evaluation of of
this cost function and you also need to
evaluate it's its gradient
because you know you are doing some kind
of a gradient desk and optimization uh
algorithm to find the the the minimum
for the cost function and for that you
need to evaluate the gradients
so to to scale up optimization based
Quantum compilers for uh for higher for
for
problems containing more qubits you need
to somehow uh increase the performance
the computational performance of this
cost function and that's the point where
group or Master Technologies comes into
the uh into the play
basically uh
to do this job we use then fpga based
accelerator
the reason behind the choosing fpga and
not GPU maybe I will explain later
uh
now I I would like to tell you uh more
about uh these fpga things so you may
know that when an fpga chip you have
many programmable uh Hardware uh units
each
okay you can program this uh these
Hardware units but you you cannot change
their program during execution time and
that's a big issue with fpgas because
you have a finite amount of resources
given on on the on the chip and for
example if you want like would like to
increase computational concurrency you
will need to implement more of these
resources if you would like to increase
the the number of supported qubits you
also need to increase the usage of
resources in this direction or if you
would like to increase the computational
accuracy you also need to to give more
resources for this and since you have a
finite amount of resources you need to
come up with some kind of reasonable
trade-off between between these three
dimensions
on top of that
you need to come up with an
implementation on the fpga chip that can
support an arbitrary Quantum circuit
made of single qubit rotations and
conditioner two qubit gates I just
showed you some slides before because
this is what is involved in in our
Quantum compiling process
and you need this functionality without
uh the reprogramming or or
recompiling the the fpga because this
takes much time
okay so basically you need to have a
full-fledged uh Universe the quantum
computer simulator implemented on the
fpga chip
to to solve or to
to increase the computational speed
and of course
doing it doing this this work in a raw
vhdi programming it's it's very
troublesome
and
solution for this problem was uh was
given by the high level development
framework of product Technologies
basically we are speaking about Java
based development framework
that is designed to to translate higher
level objects into low level vhdl
components which can then be processed
with the
and to place and Route on the fpga chip
by the low-level tools of the hardware
vendors
the okay this high level development
framework coming from maxella
the realization of so-called data flow
programming model if some of you are not
that much familiar with this concept it
is very easy to understand you just need
to
think about long production line for
example carrying some some cars over the
line and at each point you have machines
to do some work on the on on the cars
and if the production line is well
pipelined so you have many cars over the
the line then you can say that
that each machine
can do with his job and you can reach a
high level of of concurrency okay the
same can be
imagined by by flowing some streams of
data through the fpga chip and having
the components on the fpga chip to
[Music]
to get
some transformation on the data elements
uh if you are clever enough you can
retrieve the cost function at the end
from the fpga chip
okay and the DS data flow engine can be
understood as a combination of of the
fpga hardware itself and this data flow
programming model okay so the this is a
way how we try to to implement our
Universal quantum computer simulator on
the fpga chip but to this end we need to
to think about Quantum gate operations
in the context of data flow
programming okay here is a sketch that
might help you to understand the the
main ideas
let's say we have a unitary V the
quantum gate operations can be break
down onto operations on the individual
Columns of the unitary V because each
column can be considered as a the
quantum mechanical State and the
elements of the columns are basically
the the amplitudes complex amplitudes
uh of the superposition
uh made of the basis vectors
corresponding
to the state to the product state of the
quantum qubits for example the first
babies in the first base is vectors all
the qubits can be for example in state
zero in the next basis State we have one
the qubit in state one and the other two
in state 0 and and so on so we can label
all of the basis vectors according to
the individual state of the qubits
if now we have a Quantum gate that
operates on the second qubit if we start
the labeling from zero then the the
qubit labeled by Red is the in the
second qubit so if we have a gate
operation acting only on the second
qubit
then the other two qubits and the in
this example uh need to uh
be unchanged
you know so the quantum operation
mixes
only amplitude
that
that differs only in the beat
associated with the qubit on which the
gate operation is applied
okay and this way
we are combined the quantum gate
operation is combining
each time
a pairs of such amplitudes which are
labeled by these colored lines and the
output of this gate operation
replaces the transformed amplitudes at
the same position so the gate operation
has two inputs and two outputs and since
it's a linear transformation it can be
represented by a two by two Matrix
and now having The Columns of the
unitary V flowing through this gate
operation
why it
select and combine some some of the
amplitudes we can you know the data flow
model of the gate operation
of course there is much more detail that
need to be put in place here is the the
scheme of our Quantum gate
implementation of the of the Quan of the
fpga chip first of all you need a
component producing data related to the
gate operation you need to tell the gate
on which qubit it should operate this is
called Target qubit you you also need to
give the label of the control qubit in
case you are simulating a two qubit
control gate and this component also
needs to generate the that two by two
unitary Matrix of the transformation
we have discussed a slide ago
okay another component is responsible
for the iterations uh over the the
basis
and for each base it needs to determine
determine if its pair on which the
transformation is is applied basically
we need to just flip the bit on the
position of the target qubit okay this
can be done easily
so having the indexes of the of the
amplitude pairs we need to select these
these elements from the stream of of
unitary uh
unitary V to this end we Multiplex this
stream into two arms and on one of the
arms we apply a stream offset the offset
parameter here is basically the
difference between these two indices in
this specific example having uh
having the gate acting on on qubit
number three this is uh for example 48
minus eight no 89 minus 81.
okay and uh on the other arm of this
data stream we need to
we need to counterbate the latency
associated with stream Offset you know
you you can just pick some elements from
the thin air you need to feel uh on
own cheap memory with with the elements
coming from unitary V and this needs
several uh Cycles from the execution and
to countervate this latency we need to
put a stream 54 on the uh other other
arm and this is a very important point
of the design because it tells you that
that this design of the of the gate
operation is memory intensive you need
to implement
much of the own cheap memory resources
and the amount of of this memory is also
limiting factor of how many gate
operations you you can get implemented
on on the chip
the final component is the unitary
transformation
itself okay you need to stream here the
two by two unitary Matrix of the
transformation you also need to know the
state of the control qubit because you
need to decide whether apply or not the
transformation in the case of two qubit
gate and also you need to know the the
state of the target qubit to know
whether you are calculating
uh the upper or the the bottom bun of
the of the amplitude pairs
okay uh basically this unitary
transformation is a linear combination
of the amplitudes with complex values so
we are having here uh two complex
multiplications and one complex addition
okay to do a multiplication with the
with numbers on the fpga chip you have
you can utilize the so-called Digital
Signal processing unit
Beach have
uh 18 and 27 bit input ports to do to
calculate the
multiplication of two signed integers
okay I I don't want to go into details
but according to our
test having a 32-bit
fixed Point representations for the for
the amplitude and for the uh
the transformation
unitary is sufficient to get good
results
and the job here is to to tile this
32-bit multiplications over uh multiple
DSP units as efficient uh as you can do
okay to this end we
we need to split this 32-bit numbers
into big chunks
we use of course uh 16 bit
chunks labeled by a DOT A1 B Dot and B1
and if we would like to multiply numbers
these are real numbers uh A and B we are
ending up with the following expression
here we need to calculate uh
A1 times B1 then a naught times B note
both
of of the multiplication takes one DSP
uh you need to to calculate
but the the expression in the in the
middle can be reformulated instead of
having two multiplication having only a
single multiplication
and another
additions by reusing this previously
calculated products with a bond B1 and a
naught B node
uh another detail is that accounting
from passive echothing for possible
overflow here we need to do
17 times 17 bit multiplication but it
still fits into the input ports of the
DSP unit so we are fine So eventually
we can do this multiplication with three
DSP units and five
additions for the additions we can use
lookup tables and
and flip-flops to to do the adequate
pipelining during the uh the calculation
and so on but we have plenty of those uh
resources
to sum up
the the
resource requirements of this linear
transformation in in overall we are
ending up with the 18 DSP units needed
for a single gate
operation and also some lookup tables
and and flip-flops now the question is
how many of these gate operations we can
place over the the chip because you know
the limiting factors are the DSP units
and the available memory on on the chip
the design is that if we place multiple
gate units on the chip then we can chain
up them into a Circle okay here is
missing one purple Arrow I don't know
why but it doesn't matter basically we
we connect the output of one gate
operation to the input of the other one
you know this is the uh a production
line
okay and you can have flow the unitary V
over this this circle and each gate
is operating on some of the elements of
the unitary V if we have a Quantum
circuit
with the larger number of gates then we
have implemented on the chip
for this case we are
buffering the the unitary B in the
onboard memory of the fpga card okay so
this is not the only body on board
memory it's much much larger
uh usually
and
then of course we can have another turn
around another Circle uh
of uh of uh of the uh unitary V along
these uh Quantum Gates
okay uh
you know uh
each Quantum gate operation
takes uh quite much
Cycles from the execution because we
need to process each element from the
inventory so each gate operation takes
four on the power of 10 clock Cycles to
accomplish one gate operation
and you need to refresh the gate
operation with new
gate data only after finishing one gate
operation
so this is done just occasionally
you hope you you understand my point so
there is enough uh having only one
component on the chip supplying uh the
gate with with metadata associated with
the gate operations we also get having
it run on
on smaller frequencies to to lift some
of the timing constraints on uh longer
data path
because it it it's sufficient to to
supply uh gates with the
with the necessary data uh this way we
also need to
to design some some
components to to manipulate with the
onboard memory to generate the
[Music]
the correct memory addresses for the uh
for the elements of the unitary ve and
of course you know we are not
calculating on uh only the cost function
but also it's it's gradient which okay
to calculate the gradient for the cost
function we need to only replace one of
the gate operations with its derivate
function okay so nothing else it is
changed just we need to supply the given
gate with a little bit different data
but we can calculate not just the cost
function but also the gradients with the
same design and
to do that we need to to to come up with
a good strategy to
to to stream this data associated with
the gradients between the the chip
itself and the onboard memory so this is
uh quite a complicated uh thing but it
can be accomplished
at the end
uh
this is the scheme representing the
resource usage on
on one of the superlogic regions of our
fpga chip
we are using this exciting style where
you 250 fpga chip which is made of four
of such SLR regions having just
a weak wiring between these these SLR
units so it's it wouldn't be a good
strategy to to go for high data
throughput between these these
these regions
instead we implemented four independent
quantum computer simulators on each of
these regions because we can split the
calculation of of gradients between
these these regions so it makes sense
and at the end on each of these super
logic regions we could place 100 and
108 Gates
[Music]
all operating in in parallel it's a
little bit detailed that we have
organized them in six blocks where the
gates in a single block operates
synchronously driven by asynchronous
clock enable signal
by the different blocks can operate
asynchronously having some five Force to
to buffer some data between them if it's
uh if it's necessary in total we had
more than 400 gate operations on the
whole fpga
chip working in in parallel and we also
can
calculate the the execution time
to calculate the cost function and it's
it's graduates because we we know in
each clock cycle what happens on the
fpga chip
okay this is given by this simple
formula we need to uh
we need to calculate the gradient
for each of the free
parameters in the model plus the the
cost function okay in on each
fpga card we can split the workload over
the four SLR regions we can do we need
to do four on the power of an
cycles for one gate operations and we
need to multiply this execution time
with the number of of round trips that
we need to
that the unitary we need to absorb to to
get the effect of all the the gates in
the
in the quantum circuits
okay we also can
can calculate uh the number of
operations performed over a second and
this model
gave us about 2.7 in Terra operations uh
per a second so I think it's a quite a
decent uh performance
uh on the Chip And if we compared this
performance with the with the CPU we end
up with a 6 or 13 times speed up
compared to a 32 core AMD processor
we had smaller speed up with the
problems including fewer qubits and
higher speed up with with more qubit
we also could
distribute the calculations over
multiple fpgas okay you know because we
need to distribute the calculation of
the gradient components
which is uh which completely fits into
the concept of a parallel for algorithm
so it can be easily distributed between
different fpgas
for this we use to CPU servers each of
them having three fpga cards and the CPU
servers were connected with the
in the simple
Network and we measured about 3 30
kilo byte per second data transmission
during the execution
and you know with this setup we we
realized the speed up up to
78 which is a nice thing because it
enabled us to scale up the quantum
decomposition up to nine qubit here we
compared our result only to kiss kit
because the other two optimization based
tools were out of the game
and you can see the difference in the
number of C node gate okay here CX
labels the number of C node Gates
and the d labels the depth of the
circuit which is practically the the
longest
sequence of gate operations along the
the circuit
in average we have achieved
gate compression more than 90 uh
five percent on average
compared to to kiss kit and we also made
improvements over the gate cons on the
online database
so we could
we could improve those circuits
okay still having a very good Fidelity
in the the composition
now the the question is how can we
further improve
these capabilities because the problem
is still that we can't go any further
than qubits and it's still
too few
you you know
and there are several ways in our mind
how to improve uh
this
this story first of all okay I I will
explain it on the next slide but the the
thing is that the the main problem is to
construct the initial gate structure and
solve the optimization problem for it it
might take even a week for a nine qubit
problem but then if we start to compress
the quantum circuit okay we can do for
example uh randomly select some of those
uh parametric two qubit building blocks
uh excluded from the circuit and try to
solve the optimization uh process once
again okay this is
this is depicted here on these figures
and our observation is that
even if we need to solve a very similar
optimization problem then to construct
the initial gaze structure we can solve
the optimization problem in the
iterations of the compression in half an
hour if if it can be solved
okay and this is a huge difference
compared to to one week
and basically we need to solve the same
optimization problem the question is
what is the difference what makes this
huge difference
the other point which is in our mind to
uh
uh as a further or future project is to
scale up the the compilation process up
to even more
qubits of course we we don't want to to
scale up the optimization process itself
but rather we we might aim to to
reorganize the quantum circuits and come
up with with the
with the smaller
groups of of quantum operations that can
be optimized within a larger Quantum
circuit okay so this is a
this is a project for the future but the
first point is is
even more interesting okay so what makes
the difference between in the efficiency
to solve this optimization problem and
the difference is is in the initial
parameter set that that is uh that we
give to the optimizer to to begin with
okay in the
in the complex compression iterations we
are simply reuse the parameter set
obtained during the the process of the
of constructing the initial Quantum
circuit and just exclude some of the
parameters that are corresponding to the
building blocks we have just randomly
select to exclude from the circuit and
the our observation is that we can solve
the new optimization problem without
this building block much easier than
constructing the initial circuit
okay we we don't have a
well defined or where formulated answer
for this question probably in the B
probably the uh
it can be explained by some hidden
structure hidden correlations between
the the qubits which are encoded by
these parameters okay I I I don't expect
that we would be able to solve this
program because if we could we could
solve the whole Quantum gate compilation
uh problem but maybe we can use machine
learning to predict those hidden
correlations between the qubit that
makes the solution for the optimization
problem much easier to find
okay since we can extract the unitary
from the quantum circuits very easily we
can prepare uh many data for for machine
learning and our idea is to to use
machine learning uh
trained on these data sets to predict uh
parameters to for the construction of
the initial parameter set okay but we
are also very excited to use these cards
which we received some months ago from
from group to use in some some other
kind of calculations which is different
from the one they were initially
designed for for example we can ask
whether we can use Grog chips grow cards
to do quantum computer simulation for
example
and the answer is that we have a design
for that but first I need to to describe
some basic concepts about the growth
chip for for you I don't want to go into
much details you can find it in a
publication really two years ago by by
group
I just want to mention some basic ideas
okay the group chip is uh is built of
several kind of functional slices
for example you have on cheap memory of
of 110 megabytes on each side
you have also some functional slices
to to make permutations and and or other
[Music]
shift element shifting like operations
on the on the tensor tensors flowing
through the the group chip there are
also some slices to calculate Matrix or
tensor products and in the middle you
have you need to do element wise
arithmetic transformation on on the
on the tensors flowing through the chip
in each Direction you have uh you or you
can utilize 32 streams
to
which can carry your your data each
stream can carry one byte element
but uh in a
uh okay they have a
320
times
parallelism okay they are made of
320 lanes and over these Lanes you can
carry one byte element
data streams
okay each of the computational slices
can perform some kind of
operations on operands
describe here at the bottom of the of
the slide so basically you can have the
operand as integer 8 up to integer 32 or
float 16 and floor 32 but the matrix
multiplication Works only on side
multiplication of integer 8 and plot 16
but you do the accumulation of matrix
multiplication the result should be
wider
okay to handle possible overflow so the
matrix multiplication results in in 32n
and float 32.
okay
we have come up with a very simple
design to use Grog chip to do quantum
computer simulation
okay first of all remember the the gate
transformation I described you some
slides ago remember we need to combine
pairs of amplitudes and since we are
making we are pairing the same amplitude
the same yes the same amplitudes from
each column we can use the vectorization
capability of the grok chip
to fetch the whole row
and do the gate operation on the whole
roll on on the pairs of whole rows at
Advance using this
this 320 Bay vectorization
okay so we need to fetch complete rows
from the stored unitaries in the memory
but since we have only one read port on
each memory slice we need to keep two
copies of these unitary matrices in the
memory and stream the rows from each of
of them and also we need the data
associated with the gate operation
having complex transformation and we
have seen that 32-bit floating point
my operations are sufficient to get
reasonable results
for our Quantum gate compilation process
it we can think about how much streams
we need to carry this data and it turns
out that to to to carry all of this data
we need 24 streams from the available 30
to one so it's it's it seems to be
viable
also if we think about the arithmetic
operations of combining these streams
here it is the top of the
of the slides you see we have two
complex multiplications and one complex
additions in total we will we will need
14
of the arithmetic logical units capable
of doing these arithmetic operations and
in total we have 16 of these units on
the chip so this also seems to be
viable and since the Grog chip is a
deterministic hardware we can also
calculate its performance in advance
okay before we we have implemented it
and it turns out that even excluding the
the matrix multiplication slices from
the picture because you know we have a
sparse gate operations
so we can't use those Elements which are
by the way the most powerful elements on
the group chip still we are getting or
we are expecting to get the 50 percent
more performance from the growth chip
than you are getting now from from the
fpga and you do the larger memory we
also
expecting to be able to
a little bit scale up the number of the
the qubits in the the composition
okay we also uh thinking about another
uh use cases for the group chip in
Quantum simulation processes in most of
these applications
the 32-bit arithmetical operations are
not sufficient we need to do double or
long double uh
edit my Peaks
the question is how we can do it on the
chip supporting negatively on the
32-bit operands
and we have designed uh
[Music]
solution for that basically as first
step we can convert an array containing
of double and long double values into an
array of of integer 64 values
and uh also
we need to we need an an exponent okay
we we can convert the double value into
an integer Value Plus an exponent but
here we Define the exponent and node uh
globally for the whole array not for its
elements but the whole array okay then
we can split
these int 64 value array
into 7 plus 1 1 sine bit chunks
okay it can be either done using this
expression and using these chunks we can
do for example matrix multiplication
directly on the uh Grog chip I don't
want to go into details but let's say
that we need to calculate uh this
sandwich product with two vectors on the
sides and the Matrix in the middle
exponentially many times to simulate
some photonic Quantum Computing
processes
okay let's uh
let's take a look for example to the
product the of these Vector times Matrix
using those uh
big chunks introduced in the previous
slide this product can be expressed
using this this formula you know here in
the formula we need to calculate each
pair of of the uh
of the chunk multiplications
to do that we can arrange the chunks of
these arrays into this uh bigger form
and we can calculate all of these pairs
in a in a single shot this this way and
also we can we can extend this procedure
to complex arithmetics as well
organizing the the values the real and
the imaginary parts of the of the values
in this blocked form so it's it's
very straightforward
of course the matrix multiplication unit
produces
32-bit integer
results so to be able to
uh
to use the results in further
calculations we need to
somehow
transform these 32 bit results back into
8-bit
chunks okay we need to do a bit shifting
accumulating and so on so it's a pretty
uh
complicated thing but it can be
implemented on the Greek chip and at the
end
in our experiment we could realize
a numerical accuracy up to 10 on the
minus
15 in this double and long double uh
arithmetic operations compared to the
CPU Oracle
also since we need to process
generally a smaller matrices not bigger
than 80 times 80 we could fit more of
these multiplications
onto the group chip at Advance
we managed to put eight of such
multiplications
at once on on the on the chip and
according to our experiment we realized
for these operations 32 times faster
performance than doing it on on with the
numpy and equipment with the blast
behind it
and and so on okay you know the
parallelism
on the CPU in this case is is governed
by the Blessed working behind the
numpy and according to our experiments
only 20 threads were utilized to the
calculation so they are still working on
on this project we are mainly focusing
now to reduce the the i o times to
transferring data between the growth
chip and the host CPU itself
and then
okay I also prepared you a little uh
demo regarding the The Grog chip and
basically it's the end of my
presentation I am just concluding our
work
so we managed to to develop a universal
quantum computer simulator on an fpga a
cheap and it helped helped us to scale
up the quantum Gates into this uh up to
nine qubits and we also have in mind
many improvements
for it
okay here is
okay here I summarize the those grants
that supported our work if you have some
if you have any questions regarding the
uh our work you can contact us or me
through this email and I will like to to
finish my presentation with that demo I
just mentioned
so
so I'm just switching this the screen
and this will be very interesting
so this is the implementation
hope you see it this is the
implementation of that double or long
double procedure multiplication on the
Grog chip okay Grog provide you a very
uh
very very intuitive tools to
to
[Music]
have to say to to make your
implementations more optimal optimal to
solve some streaming conflicts and and
so on
here you can see the data transfer
during our multiplication implementation
first we are streaming the matrices
towards the
matrix multiplication slices okay these
are those in integer 8 chunks
we are doing eight multiplications at
Advance so that's why we are utilizing
both hemispheres both sides of the Chip
and so on and here in the middle you can
see how we are recombining the resulting
32
bit results coming from the mxm slices
back into integer 8.
uh chunks to be reused in further
chained
[Music]
operations okay basically these
reorganizing into 8-bit chunks take even
more times more Cycles than the
multiplication itself
in total we are doing the multiplication
in around
uh one thousand and two hundred Cycles
foreign okay this is our limit and then
we basically do other chaining
operations here one of our uh the gifted
PhD student Gregory Morse developed the
gray code
uh
okay so so to do further calculations we
need to to produce additional
computational data
and we are doing it directly on on the
chip to exclude or to reduce the the
communication through the PCI slot and
this is done by transferring some rows
and cons of the input Matrix in Gray
code ordering so to this end Gregory
implemented this gray code counter and
gray code
uh style updating of the of the Matrix
and this is what you are seeing now
basically we are transforming the one
byte chunks on of the uh of the matrices
okay so I think my time
[Music]
it's it's a
so it's finished and I also came at the
end of my talk so I am very grateful
again I'm very grateful for the
opportunity to present our results here
at this colloquium and if you have any
questions don't hesitate to ask us
foreign
are there any questions
I see something in the chat
oh
okay chat I see the chat what's the
performance running on GPU
[Music]
okay we are not okay we don't have the
implementation for for a GPU that's a
good question anyway
uh
we don't have that that comparison uh
our goal was to scale up the
the capability to to generate a Quantum
circuit to compile Quantum programs into
Quantum circuits and this is the the
I think the main message of of our work
to use DFE as an accelerator for this is
only a a tool
okay so we we didn't
have uh in in our forecast to compare
its performance to other type of
accelerators we just wanted to uh
decompose larger and larger unitaries
but you know the way the reason why we
like
data flow engines or fpgas is the way
they
we can utilize concurrency or or
parallelism on on these devices because
you know if you would like to use GPU
for example to to make parallel the gate
operations it's it's not that easy
because you know as I told you you need
to to transform pairs of the amplitudes
and these pairs might be distant from
each other and if you start to do
parallel execution of gate operations
even if they commute with each other
they can overlap
with each other and
and eventually they can interfere with
with each other so it's it's not an easy
task to to ensure the correctness of the
calculations okay and if you if you
would like to
to keep up uh such a parallel
calculation you will need to pay some
penalty
if some performance penalty to ensure
the correctness and that's why we like
fpgas because of this data flow
programming model we don't need to pay
any performance penalty
Okay so
maybe they might be some GPU
implementation that might run even
faster than our dfp implementation but I
am not that sure about it
because it's it's not that easy to make
the simulation of quantum circuits
parallel
it's not not that trivial
[Music]
anywhere else
foreign
thank you very much Peter for your
presentation and
um she is uh so I'll get out onto the
the web and uh we'll pick up uh more
questions and so forth and I assume that
you'll be available to uh answer
questions and so forth is that uh that's
the case and yes I hope you enjoyed a
bit the talk may be it was a bit too
much at the end
but uh
okay I hope you enjoy it yeah thank you
thank you all